hello oh hi hey yeah hey guys - hey no
girls allowed you know guitar Genki your
go to Yankee it's gonna be really good I
really like it I think it's gonna be
really good - guys I'm Juliette that's
always a thing
Oh Julie I say we go Juliet Yankee I'm
foxtrots one of us where's the fourth
one of us I'm the matter
it's the Matt can someone explain really
quick how you play okay so one person
has the gun yeah yes so you're not
allowed to say if you have the gun from
now on it's not me one person is the
murderer and two people are you guys I'm
an impenetrable wall of bulletproof
manliness you have the knife how can we
know it's you come back here you little
scum shitty guy come back oh [ __ ] I drop
my knife wait how's like I just got my
knight there we go okay what do you
doing with that gun slave skills strafe
skills what you gonna do huh
[ __ ] whoa all right yes let's all go up
on the balcony yes no it's my balcony I
came up here to be alone
yeah throw your knife at somebody
Oh No all right let's all jump on three
one oh geun-tae
I'm not falling for your tricks [ __ ]
okay beautiful you are
I'm right behind you that was propane
yeah I thought it was like a whoa what
are you doing with that thing oh I'm
just giving you some sweet aspirin
give me some space not afraid of you
okay sit down
Sara sit down take a chat take a chat
sit down everyone sure if you're not
telling who died
oh the murders is loose I'm a knife in
my back come on my god crazy [ __ ]
I'm I just saw um with knife in a hand
there for a second
wait let me cuz I just showed up who was
it what is it Zulu what Yozora dance for
me solo dance I don't like your dancing
banks well actually still my kills over
I don't like your attitude Zulu sure I'm
trying I can't they're dancing really
well oh my god you throw the gun hey god
I got this wait which one of you which
was got this okay you're dead
I am totally innocent oh shoot me you'll
be killing your last friend here okay on
my friend come on
if you're my friend then give me a hug
stop moving goddamn it
dun dun Dada Dada oh my god
daddy's reflexes hey I was watching that
first person holy crap them skills oh my
god I should join the clan I'm waiting
for that hog market huh I'm waiting for
that hog mark ugh where who are you you
said we were friends who are you
I love November sue I am me clay okay I
am Victor okay so here's your hug in a
lion oh why why should we listen to you
he's gonna shoot all of us she's let him
go eeny Meeny the skills I Petey Petey
what's this thing I'm carrying let it go
pinecones
Asher let it go let it go Papa thank you
what do you mean you guys I mean can I
hit you with a shirt try hit me we try
coming to that yeah well I'm trying all
everyday don't you dare take my chair
pop up here yes India who's India you're
being very dirty chatter - yes I want to
show you the show who's that go whoa
settle my Shack I'll share my share with
you sharing I share my share with you
it's very sharing of you to share your
share
I know all right yeah yes where are you
guys going
I'm lost how what just happened who did
that who killed me I didn't say I heard
something it's really weird what
happened what happened I understand
so we a scam it's bugged I think mark
just died huh
[Laughter]
protects us I am trying to protect you
guys
[ __ ] oh it was my head sticking up below
Center am i I'm kilo you stay away from
you minx it's not the murder is it buddy
it's what you just know I've been
following so much of lies mixes a liar
[Laughter]
what why any meenie miney mo let's see
if it works
no well we all got to go stand by
whiskey and then I think you were a
little late with that one what are you
going no no no I don't have the keys
right here dude why don't you just take
it [ __ ] what you gonna do huh Punk you
have you what where to kill everyone
waited way to go reddit is a place where
murder is often hang out with heard
hey hey you want a shower with me go for
a swim
yeah sure hey babe they're gonna pull
yeah Wow Wow it's on it's on it's on
Thanks
show them well then it's mark that one
that one in the fall Kalin I don't like
his attitude either
I can't believe mistress tiny are we
gonna do any money McGann I'm down for
it
jeanny miny mo homewrecker is gonna get
shot in the face
what every time 100% best tactic ever
[Music]